right Wingers are completely losing
their minds over this train derailment
that took place in Ohio now one of the
reasons I've not said much about it yet
is that it is still really not clear
what or who is to blame and the right is
very quick to blame woke and racism for
the event that took place which is a
really strange thing to do and to blame
it's conceivable that what we have here
is a problem in terms of lack of
Regulation it it's really not clear yet
the NTSB report so far
says that the um uh and the the cause
here was a malfunction with a wheel
bearing which overheated and it's not
yet clear what caused the wheel bearing
to overheat now of course there are
concerns about chemicals in the area
both in the air and the impact on water
quality Mike dewine said he would be he
would stick with the bottled water for
the time being Aaron Brockovich is
expressing concern about whether there
are more harmful chemicals than what is
being revealed we we are still trying to
learn a lot about it but many on the
right have figured out what this is all
about here's Greg Gutfeld he believes
wokism is to blame mayor Pete is busy
he's got some pretty big issues that
he's dealing with for example did you
see what he said about construction
workers that it's really a problem that
their skin color doesn't match the
diversity of a community and that's
really got to upset people I remember as
a kid walking around and I was very
upset whenever I saw of mine I like a
minority construction worker I was like
my God now understand that these are two
completely separate issues and if indeed
mayor Pete weighed in about diversity of
construction workers it has nothing to
do whatsoever with this incident but Fox
News doesn't care about that they all
have to look like me you know I had that
was a secondary that was a primary
concern the the all the other things
about safety and whether the product was
so that was just that was not as
important this is the problem with
catering to the woke they don't have
time for real problems so they chase
these completely made up once train
derails or a plane crashes but they
worry about the white construction
worker offending somebody who doesn't
exist I don't believe a single person
has ever expressed a problem about a
construction worker's skin color unless
it was another skincare another
construction worker but this is the if
you want to talk about a a toxic spill
look at what look at wokism and what
what what politics is doing to every
part of life I mean okay so Greg Gutfeld
says wokism and Pete bootage being
distracted by wokism is the problem
Charlie Kirk goes even further and his
do I even call it an analysis Charlie
Kirk says the Ohio train derailment is
part of the war on white people and
remember oh the left is always victim
they're they're the victims it is the
right that is now regularly saying
Christians are the victims and white
people they're the victims and
conservatives are the victims here's
Charlie Kirk's analysis of the situation
not a single member of the Biden regime
would dare to go
to this portion of Ohio and breathe in
the air because they know it's dangerous
they know that it is actively poisoning
the citizens
of Eastern Ohio so why is it that they
kind of shrug their shoulders
and they say uh yeah okay whatever it's
very simple it's because the war on
white people continues right
why would you care for the white
working-class voters in eastern Ohio you
haven't cared about them in other
reasons or other portions and I will
prove it to you
if this train derailment happened in
downtown Atlanta in the densely
populated black neighborhoods
this would be the number one news story
it would be Flint Water Crisis 2.0 the
speed oh well that's interesting we know
how sincere Charlie Kirk is in saying he
would be just as concerned obviously if
the train derailment disproportionately
affected black people because of the
years that Charlie Kirk has spent
talking about the Flint Water Crisis oh
wait he hasn't spent years talking about
the Flint Water Crisis and so this is
yet again we are the victims it is
racist or it's Reverse Racism which is a
delightful term that they like to talk
about but what they won't discuss is
whether the train derailment might be
the result of corporate greed and
deregulation now I'm not ready to say it
is understand I want to follow the facts
and based on the NTSB report so far it
isn't clear to me that the issue here is
one of corporate greed and deregulation
but if we're speculating about what this
is and we're going to speculate well
it's because of woke or it's because of
anti-white racism or whatever the case
may be if we're speculating let's
include more reasonable speculation as
well then we go to Marjorie Taylor green
Marjorie Taylor green says the issue
here is Pete butterjudge that's really
the problem that's the cause but the
real problem Sean is Pete bitajege he's
the Secretary of Transportation and he's
more interested in equity and inclusion
in his hiring practices and Grant giving
schemes and and obviously probably chest
fading or something like that then he is
rail safety now chest feeding this is
something that Lauren bobert started
with Pete butterjudge it's just straight
up homophobic Buddha judge took
paternity leave
that's the story and they talk about
maybe he was home chest feeding and of
course this is what they are saying
because Pete Buda judge is gay that this
this is a homophobic attack on Pete
Buddha judge If This Were you know I
don't know uh
I don't know I I was going to say George
Santos but Santos is gay the point here
is they're talking about Pete bootage's
chest feeding because of the stereotypes
about gay men being feminine so the
homophobia continues but more
importantly here Marjorie Taylor green
is saying oh there's a Democrat who is
Secretary of Transportation let's blame
him for what took place in Ohio rather
than all of the Ohio infrastructure and
political uh establishment which is
overwhelmingly run by Republicans no no
no it's the fault of Buddha judge in
Washington DC and that's where we have
real danger in our country yeah you see
Pete Budaj was never qualified for the
job sort of like she's not qualified for
her job I believe we need to haul him in
in our committees and start questioning
him over what's actually happening in
his Department because train derailment
is happening every single day and now
thousands of people uh Birds animals
they're all sick and we we don't know
the consequences of this horrible
accident in East Palestine yeah you know
she throws in train derailments are
happening every single day that's one of
those statements that's true and is
completely misleading
when you look at what that means there's
about a thousand incidents a year that
are called train derailment incidents so
it is like three a day understand that
the overwhelming majority of these are
minor incidents with absolutely no
injuries never mind deaths often
involving a city uh rail Transit like
Subways and commuter rails and this sort
of thing often they're weather related
their derailments of you know a part of
one car uh and it's really not
representative of any kind of
particularly major problem and of course
it happens whether the Secretary of
Transportation is a democrat or a
republican under Elaine Chao as
Secretary of Transportation you also had
about a thousand derailments of
different kinds of years so it's all
dishonest it's all nonsense but they
don't care they just want to find
someone to blame
um one more clip here real quick this is
Jesse Waters saying this is the the
racist black EPA administrator trying to
hurt white people so where's the EPA
if they say my plastic straw is
destroying this country
then they must be all over a
cancer-causing gas bomb in the Ohio
River Valley right
or the random toxic Ash that's raining
down in Illinois
by the way it's funny how now suddenly
conservatives care about pollution in
the environment actually the EPA
administrator Michael Reagan no relation
to Ron is too zoned in on electric
school buses to care about poison
drinking water he just announced pledge
to support electric school buses
Nationwide
you have cancer here's an electric bus
does this guy Reagan even know anything
about the environment well we looked
into him and the only reason he was
nominated to run the EPA was because he
promised to fight off environmental
racism
is this his idea of fighting
environmental racism spilling toxic
chemicals on poor white people in Ohio
why do you make everything about race
they say to the left why why do you see
race in every issue well it seems like
these right Wingers are very much seeing
race in this issue unhinged brain worms
is what they're suffering from but
people hear it and they fall for it
one of our sponsors today is mosh
whether you're at the gym on the go
between meals mosh protein bars are the
smart snack to keep your body and brain
fueled there's six delicious flavors
like blueberry almond crunch peanut
butter chocolate Crunch cookie dough
crunch each mosh bar comes packed with
12 grams of protein six grams of fiber
but also important nutrients like
vitamin B vitamin D
Omega-3s and only one gram of sugar and
160 calories I've tried tons of
different protein bars really you can't
beat the taste and the texture of mosh I
love these my favorite is the chocolate
Crunch simple satisfying now that I'm
back in the gym I'll snack on one of
these after a workout mosh is also a
mission-driven company with a portion of
all proceeds donated to support women's
brain health research through the
women's Alzheimer's movement at
Cleveland Clinic mosh is giving my
audience 20 off plus free shipping on
your first six count trial pack go to
moshlife.com Pacman the link is down
below